Kevin harder to get ahead everyone  standing at State Farm arena runner  looks blades it into tray two seconds  watch race fluttered  [Applause]  what a shame  deserve  they deserve this win  they scrap this game out they came out  with a lot of energy and they got a  chance right now in the next point one  seconds to go on with a win again no  help by Joelle and beef  [Applause]  what a play by Trey young the Florida  then he has perfected and getting all  the love on the sidelines no man he's  putting together a heck of a game  there's a tenth of a second there is no  time for any kind of catch and shoot  the only thing Philadelphia can do is  tap one in at the rim